ils ont presque 40 ans ils sont beaucoup
plus âgés que les bâtiments alentour les
225 sol du mile vont devoir pourtant
être abattus d'ici quelques mois
en cause un terrain qui s'affaisse par
certains endroits et un champignon qui
tue progressivement les arbres la mairie
a donc présenté récemment un nouveau
projet aux habitants lors d'une réunion
publique
objectif redessiné la venue ce projet
propose de ramener la circulation
piétons vélos poussettes valise etc
au centre dumas y est de recréer
avertissements de part et d'autre du my
en éloignant les arbres ce qu'il y aura
des arbres bien entendu en éloignant les
arbres des habitations des immeubles le
nouveau projet devrait coûter 4 millions
d'euros entièrement financés par la
ville qui espère une aide de
l'agglomération et si l'utilité des
travaux est reconnu par tous le projet
est sujet à quelques critiques
la future avenue de 500 mètres ne
prévoit qu'une seule allée centrale
contre 2 actuellement et pourrait
engendrer des problèmes de sécurité
entre piétons et cyclistes par exemple
on s'aperçoit lorsqu'on circule à vélo
effectivement que six mètres de large
s'est certes large mais quand il ya du
monde comme tout à l'heure à la sortie
du lycée hôtelier par exemple il y à des
conflits entre piétons et cyclistes
donc il vaudrait mieux moins deux bandes
séparés - large à mettre ça quand on
considère que c'est parfait pour les
cyclistes
mais on est absolument certain que ça va
générer des conflits les guenons
courteau ont jusqu'au 2 novembre pour
faire part de leurs remarques sur un
registre installé à la maison de
quartier auguste renoir
la fin des travaux est prévue elle pour